The Okavango Delta a biodiversity hotspot
in the heart of one of Africa's
most important
freshwater systems.
Its pulse
is maintained by a river structure
that begins deep in the Angolan highlands,
in an area locals call Lisima Iya Mwono,
the source of life.
One half is a constant flow.
The Cuito river is steady, carrying,
nutrient rich water from Angola's
hidden source lakes, released slowly
through miles of peatlands.
The other half drives the pulse.
The Cubango is unpredictable,
rocky and rough.
His water flows faster, pumping
seasonal flows into the system.
On Namibia's border with the Angola,
these two lifelines
become the Kavango River,
which becomes
the Okavango River in Botswana,
where reedbeds and floating
papyrus islands filter the water
before diffusing into the Okavango Delta.
This system is as vital as it is delicate.
If anything begins to affect it,
the consequences
could be catastrophic.
That's why National Geographic and
De Beers are working through the
Okavango Eternal Partnership.
Building on the work done
by local communities
to know the rivers and the ecology
that keeps them alive.
Through intense expeditions,
cutting edge research technologies
and expert indigenous guidance,
they are building an understanding
of how this ecosystem works.
Sharing their research
with local organizations
and policymakers to better protect it.
Keeping a finger on the pulse.
Making sure the heart of
the Okavango keeps beating.